hello we have a lot to do today we're
going to do a group number and we're
going to do a trio we got to figure out
who needs extra help and who is flying
down the road ready for the next
challenge
tatum
i want to see you be alert i want to see
you be in it the whole time
yeah you're strong dancers get it up
there
and one of you is going to be in the
tree and one of you is not going to be
in the trio if i had to do it right now
i'd pick leah hands down
i feel like bella's standing there going
i wish i had the chance to be on the
trail
bella probably knows the trio
we only have one day until the
competition and both of these dances
still need work so i'm gonna let
bella who i may even call my little
teacher's assistant work with this group
well i work with the three kids in the
trio bella knows what she's doing and i
trust her to tell the other kids how to
do it
here we go kiddos
trio let's rock
[Music]
tomorrow's competition i still don't
have a third girl from my trio i'm so
torn a one two a three a four go five a
six i just can't find tatum sparkle she
had it when i first met her i just can't
find it right now
aaliyah is just really
controlled and refined and
gonna stay in her safety zone i want to
take her out of her safety zone they
both know the dance perfectly they've
both rehearsed it the costume fits both
of them they both want to do it
i just need to see more from both of
them who do you feel is doing better
right now
leah jess even said it i do i do think
it will be
i mean if they want to win
okay now scoot to right here tatum so
you're right he'll be like oh my god i
was thinking the same thing like big and
dramatic no no no no no just to right
here just right here let me do it so
what do you say you say i think this
monster is cranky i hope i don't tip
this yeah what do you say i think this
monster is kind of cute oh my god i was
thinking the same thing
it's like
you're being stupid big around the wave
go and let's end bent leg
and bent arm yep
let me see what happens if you go
up
up turn around three and let's make it
cutesy exactly what leah's doing
how do girls feel
right tatum
leah
i will be deciding who is going to be in
the trio tomorrow when you get to the
competition so make sure you come ready
this final spot in the trio is super
important to me i've only worked with
these girls for three weeks i don't want
to make a quick decision i want to give
it to who is 100 right for the trio from
what i saw tatum i thought she was doing
a really good job so i just i appreciate
you know you're so sweet thank you
is an incredible technician i think
stylistically tatum suits kinley and
brooklyn better to me it's a stylistic
thing more than it is anyone executing
things is better or not as good when
leah goes through and still dances
there's nothing i'm going to take away
from that girl i have mad respect for
how she performs based on what she goes
through daily so i would not be upset at
all i think she'll be very upset i don't
think i'll be upset
hayden's mom trying to act like she
wouldn't be upset
if her kid wasn't giving the dance
that's not true that's a flat out lie
she's trying to make me look like an ass
for being upset excuse the french i mean
i do feel like it's kind of shady
potato my filled in the ending you're
fine with right cool the beginning i'm
not weird because it's practically
freestyle i feel like kind of stressed
for the trio people because again they
haven't had as much time to work on that
so
that's just a little stressful for them
and the moms in it if you ask me like
i don't know
like i feel
uh
you know when you feel like there's like
tension
that's what i'm feeling like right now
like right now my heart is beating
because i'm just like
something just doesn't feel right it
doesn't what's the tension that doesn't
feel right a lot of other energy
well yeah and i don't like i don't like
to start drama either but angie
usually you're the
the perky angie and like right now it's
like i can feel it
my mom always taught me if you don't
have anything nice to say you shouldn't
say anything at all and so that's the
stance i'm taking right now
but you really no i'm that's it like the
shadiness that was going on over here
period and it was i know you were
talking crap about my kid i know that
stuff was going on and y'all are over
here being ugly i'm not talking smack
about your kid oh come on now jenny i
mean cause i said what do you have to
say to your friends you're not being
real i'm not being real i'm not scared
of you angie i'm not intimidated by you
either i know trust me listen i called
it what did i say she's gonna come at me
today what did i say all i know is that
our kids are back they're hearing us
argue which is not and they need to
focus on the competition that's what i
think
[Music]
[Music]
you